[Music]
[Music]
welcome to life is short i'm your host
justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
uh and with me as always in these
quarantine times certainly always this
is a very special oh yeah sorry
quarantine edition of life is short
oh that's good and we did it that was a
good intro yeah uh maybe you should do
the intro from now on nope um and with
me as always is my uh
keeping me honest
uh
my brother christian hello
hello what was that you know
people
people have been saying it's
an awful way to start a sentence people
have been saying about me oh
wow i know oh you called yourself i know
uh but i have read this numerous times
now that people say i sound like the guy
from bob's burgers oh yeah yeah you told
me that
and um i don't really
but every time i watch bob's burgers i
really like it i don't know why i don't
watch it more often i know people
people whose um comedic opinions yeah i
respect a lot really like bob's burger
so i feel like i would like it to wait
but which guy bob
oh
the burgers you know what i sort of look
a little bit like him too someone put
like a bob's burger cartoon
on facebook or something and i was like
oh not only do i sound like because he's
the one i kind of look like him now he's
the one with the mustache
hell you know what i didn't tell you
this but our friend john togo said last
night so i put a little video of you on
instagram he said with your mustache
you're starting to look like ned
flanders
uh maggie told me that oh like
a year ago and i was so insulted and
she's like that's not a bad thing
no in fact that's a nice guy like that's
not a good defense yeah i know but ned
flanders also has like uh remember when
he took his shirt off yeah he's like
ripped i love that episode uh when he
does the tennessee williams play that's
funny
yeah when they do streak streetcar yeah
oh my god that's good um
i guess though i mean now that i think
about it as far as simpsons characters
goes ned flanders is probably one of the
better ones to look like right yeah sure
you don't want to go you don't want to
look like this
yeah mayor quimby homer um what's that
song stella you're putting me through
hella
um god is that good uh speaking of
tennessee williams williams
tennessee williams and um
and people of certain lifestyles from
that time who couldn't be um free and
weren't tolerated uh we have been
getting a lot of feedback from last
week's episode where we discussed the
wizard of oz and that's a really good
segue i don't know where you're going
for a second
uh yeah we were getting a lot of
feedback about um we were discussing the
wizard of oz if you didn't listen to
last week's um you really should it is a
no i'm sorry um we were talking about
the characters the wizard of oz in the
wizard of oz the tin man
the lion and
the scarecrow and how they were we
described them as being because morocca
had been on previously and he
pointed out that they were zanies a
bunch of people on instagram one in
particular book and facebook sorry
facebook uh a fellow named bill flood
william flood
who follows me on instagram um was
very accurately pointed out i think that
we were wrong
that those characters are not zany's
they wouldn't be described as zany's
rather they are they're called uh nances
a nance the lion specifically is a nance
which is a type of character was it was
a like queer code
um
in fact nathan lane he pointed out
starred in an amazing broadway play
called the nance about those actors
who were laboring this let's cut to the
chase yeah so people get the weirdest
thing about that i did a the first
reading of that played the nance oh cool
with nathan lane and i forgot that
that's great um
so
to summarize people basically said my
segway was really good but my setup was
time it was horrible sorry
basically people were like oh you guys
need to re-watch the wizard of oz
because
if you do you'll clearly see that the
the point of it is that the um the
cowardly lion the scarecrow and the tin
man the things they were lacking they
thought they were lacking they had
within them the entire time yes courage
brain heart and our older brother damien
who's smarter than us
not that you have to be smarter than us
to point this out no but he texted me us
about it and he said i think you guys
missed the point a little bit long text
long text uh and he very thoroughly
thoroughly explained
how we missed the point in depth but i
would like to and i agree we did miss
the point well yes it had been years
since i've seen it yes and we've since
since yeah we saw the other night yeah
so justin and i uh after all this have
this flood of criticism came our way we
decided to re-watch the wizard of oz
with sober eyes
and
uh first of all
all you people are right including our
brother that that is the point and bill
flood however i would like to push back
a little bit
as i think you would like to push back a
little bit in that
in the story in the movie
the the lion is lacking courage the
scarecrow's lacking brain
the tin man is lacking heart however
the only one that's clear to me
is this is the lion lacking courage yes
the other two don't necessarily need
they really all lack courage that's what
we notice when we watch that's kind of
the common they're all lacking courage
yeah
the scarecrow doesn't really seem to be
lacking a brain as much as he's lacking
a good sense of bodily control yes you
know he falls a lot he's awkward but he
seems plenty smart because let's face it
if you don't have a brain
you're not going to be able to exist
same with the heart you know that's true
there are things that a body
needs to live yeah whereas courage is
not one of those things so i think it's
a lot easier to show a lack of courage
than it is to show
a lack of a brain or heart
but i still say i think they could have
done a better job
in the movie if not to [ __ ] on it like
one of the most classic movies of all
time but
i think they would it would have been
more effective if they had more clearly
shown that the scarecrow needed a brain
because he was dumb in some way and the
tin man thought he needed a heart
because he was like felt like he was a
sociopath or something and then at the
end you realize that
they didn't need that well i
went down a little google hole a little
wikipedia hole and um i discovered that
the original scripts i don't remember
the book i read the book when i was a
kid the al frank bomb book bomb um but i
i apparently in the original script for
the wizard of oz it was a four-page
outline uh because recent fantasy films
had not fared well uh the original
recommended toning down or removing the
magical elements of the story in his
outline the scarecrow was a man so
stupid that the only employment opened
him was literally scaring crows from
cornfields while the tim tim woodsman
was a criminal so heartless he was
sentenced to be placed placed in a tin
suit for eternity torture that softened
him into somebody gentler and kinder and
that vision was similar kinder
what is the kind like his vision was
similar to larry simmons 1925 film
adaptation i think i would have enjoyed
that movie a little more well yeah it's
and i also understand why they toned it
down because that would have been that's
a kid's kid's movie um all right wizard
of oz let's let's get off it okay but it
is but uh
basically we were wrong
and
i think it's a little flawed it's also
as our brother also pointed out judy the
other thing that confuses it is that
judy garland
is
certainly acts older i guess she was
only 16 or 17 when she did the movie but
um that character is supposed to be
younger in the book she's a little girl
yeah and so there's absolutely no
potentiality for
any sort of like confusion with the with
the adult male character like we talked
about in the last episode i never
thought it was creepy because they are
those adults are are people that we meet
in the beginning they're real people in
um
in kansas that's right so it's not
threatening because she
they already established that she feels
safe with them but it's not so in the in
the book i don't think i don't know
about that i don't think it is okay
shorties
feel free to
continue to
um
a thing that justin and i have been
doing um with maggie in wall and
quarantine to pass the time past the
time we've come up with and this is her
idea uh quarantine questions we call
them and we have a big vase that we
write little sticky note question you
know sticky notes whatever you want
whenever the mood strikes you you just
write a question and they tend to be
hypotheticals like would you rather
um
this or that they're they tend to be
would you rather questions yeah um if if
you had to pick one of these two things
what would you pick you know those are
usually my favorites yeah they're more
they lead to the most fruitful
discussions yeah yeah if any shortie or
listener would like to write in
with a good hypothetical good would you
rather oh yeah that's good i'd love to
uh discuss it yeah that'd be fun uh life
is short we're running.com yeah um but
the one we had yesterday we thought was
fun was
uh if for a year
you had to
either a
have a propeller beanie on your head
any time you were outside for a year and
assuming that this quarantine doesn't
last so long let's say
um
a propeller beanie on your head just
whenever you went outside yeah whenever
you're outside
or
if
any time you were outside
instead of walking you had to skip
for one year and so christian and i did
versions of what a skip is we because
there's a more muted skip that's that
you can do it still looks weird though i
i'm you you can try it out at home i
would argue that try to do a subtle skit
i would argue that the subtle skip is
weirder than the exaggerated
because the exaggerated skip is like
everyone knows you're a guy who's
skipping yeah and like that's a little
weird but they're people are thinking
there must be a reason he's skipping but
the subtle skip is creepy but
i i think with either thing you will
quickly become the guy who does that
either whether it's like oh that's the
guy with the propeller beanie or the guy
like a hipster with a propeller beanie
yes that's true that's you know i don't
think i've ever seen someone wear a
propeller beanie in public who's not
like a character like he's not a cat i
don't think i've even seen a kid wear it
outside of a cartoon kid or like
tweedledee and tweedledum which
um means that
so many people would look at you that's
you would draw a lot of attention so
it's skipping no but skipping you
imagine going up like a happy guy
getting into whole foods
whole foods is one thing i'm picturing
you skipping the whole foods whistling
whole foods is one thing but imagine
going my big hang up was going to a ball
game
like going to a state an outdoor stadium
what do you mean you skip at a ball i
mean you sit at a ball game but what if
you're skipping to your you'd have to
skip to your seat down the aisle you
just have to give yourself plenty of
time and get there early
oh you'd go to the stadium earlier yeah
to avoid what if you're ridiculed you're
gonna have to go to the bathroom if you
get there that early you're gonna i that
i wouldn't drink beer i wouldn't go to a
baseball you know you also be due to
other liquids also you don't have to go
to a baseball game that year
aren't you excited to go to a game again
but although it seems like crazy now i
would pick skipping for the record
yeah uh you don't both have a big
skipping rather than propelling it's
also a good exercise yeah sure
also it's it is less embarrassing i
think but you do walk a lot over the
course of a year think about that
and propeller beanie is just like part
of your outfit
it's it's a lot easier to do the
propeller oh much easier you get better
shape skipping though and
and and here's you take it off and and
you can go inside you stop skipping when
you go to the movies or or some or an
indoor stadium you go to a dome you
could also take off your beanie once you
go inside too
yep
yep
uh so
yeah so all that over she won that one
for a while
all right let's make it calm yeah okay
we're good every week we'll try to talk
about um one of those and as christian
said uh feel free to give us any good i
hope you're sitting down
speaking of sitting down uh we are going
to check in
with
easily our favorite guest of the show um
our grandmother a lot of you have been
very kindly wondering how she's doing
and uh i just
i just checked in with her myself so i
thought maybe we can all check in with
her
i wonder if she's going to act
differently because i told her we'd be
calling on the she'd be on the show
she's going to put on a like podcast
voice she didn't have much of a podcast
voice so for those of you who don't
that's true
she's 103 our grandmother she's in lake
worth florida
maybe we should have said that
and hopefully she'll answer
hello
should i try her again try her on the
house phone
on her cell phone why don't you call her
on her cell phone what she could be
doing
she emailed me last night she we sent
her um because we've been hello hello
did you call a couple minutes ago i did
where were you
i was answering the phone and then it
died at my hand oh cause you didn't
charge me i had to go scrounging around
for another one and you were gone look
what you've done sorry
sorry
so where are you right now we are in our
little
podcast
we have a little like podcast
yeah we're in our little uh podcast room
i don't know quarantined yeah we're
quarantined what are you doing i'm in my
living room
you're keeping me from my walk you know
this oh oh sorry
all right well walked over three times a
day
either with a cane or with my walker
what else can i do
well that but that's but that's kind of
what you were doing before the
quarantine right well
okay
i mean
how different you go out every day
yeah yeah yeah we go out every day we
play catch we play a lot of catch i just
set up a basketball hoop it's all right
for you to go out but i can't go out you
cannot go out which is why um
so you got i sent you toilet paper
is it is it just because i'm old but i
can't fly yeah
yeah
yeah not only old but very old
and and you uh people know this if they
listen to your your
episode on the show but you are one of
the few people that survived the spanish
flu oh wait a second wait a second
okay
try it again okay
this is my question for you a little bit
better all right we can talk about i
want to be able to hear you you know
well you have to let me get you that
hearing aid
a better hearing aid
oh it's bad hearing
i know i could because you because you
should have a better hearing aid
you're hearing it is 10 years old
all right hey can you get my hearing aid
in and everything okay how are you but
how are you doing people want to know
how they say where did you find those
little rolls with toilet paper i have
never seen anything like it well you
know i feel a little guilty saying this
but i
a couple weeks ago when we were trying
to get encourage you to stay home we
didn't want you to leave so i ordered it
it's very soft and lovely thank you so
much honey oh good okay well this is
like an ad for this chinese toilet paper
somebody last week said they were in
walmarts and they were delivering
some angel toilet paper to them so they
bought a whole bunch of them and they
dropped off a package to me and i said
well i'm not out yet but thank you very
much so wow
i'm pretty well fixed oh all right well
then you'll be fine for a while i think
people are so people have been dropping
stuff off for you we've been sending you
groceries because nobody wants you to
leave
hi
yes he's right here question
good morning
christian i don't know what's wrong with
my phone
well you know i'm a little far away from
the phone because uh justin is closer to
the phone so that might be why it's hard
to hear me maybe yeah well
but i think just generally people want
to know how you're getting by because a
lot of old people
are this this is you know the most
dangerous for them
are you afraid oh you know how dangerous
for me can it be honey i've passed the
time that i should have died so long ago
that
i don't even think about it
oh wow well that's
good
i goals i should be able to go out and
do my own shopping uh yeah you should
well but
not to be able to go to the store
i know it's annoying but but you don't
want to catch this thing you don't want
to get this thing no i don't want that
little bugger on me
because it's not a good way it's not it
would be very unpleasant to have it
would be so hard to breathe and i had it
you know grandma grandma did you know
that that christian and i we think we
had like a mild christian had a more
severe than i did and his girlfriend
maggie who you know had it pretty bad
uh a
virus
this is very annoying you know i have a
neighbor downstairs that normally lives
in a little town a little coastal town
near boston
son drives her down and then he comes
down and picks her up
jack this comes for the winter
and he can't come he says i he's got to
get the okay from the doctor
i said what does that mean well he
doesn't know if it's good to travel to
come down and all this stuff
so she's still here and she's usually
gone by the first of april
so i mean isn't anybody on the roads
not
really i mean the roads are
where we live
you know we've just started going out uh
because we were quarantined for a while
they had no the roads have been like
there's no certainly no traffic heading
into
new york i mean we live in a very like
trafficking area in connecticut and it's
it's like
and
los angeles there's no traffic people
are saying
story in a book guy reads a lot of crazy
stories i would say now who would have
thought about that's never going to
happen that couldn't happen i would not
believe
this but what are you talking about you
stay home
yeah but isn't that what they did during
the spanish flu
wow
grandma isn't that what they did during
the spanish film
all right
she can't hear um grandma we uh hey we
we love you we just wanted uh people to
know that you're okay we want to know
you're okay so well i'm okay honey i'm
i'm as okay as i can be
okay well what do you what have you been
doing to pass the time besides walking
three times a day which is great
well what do i even do yesterday i was
doing a wash at this time
what have you been
are you reading anything good i've been
trying to clean out drawers so that when
john comes the moving won't be so tough
it's going to be great and and we have
plenty of place here at the new house
and you're going to really love it
i i i just heard that you're going to
love it and we're going to love having
you up here
and um and now you have tons of toilet
paper to do anything with you can you
can pull a prank on your neighbor and
yeah either tp their apartment
well i've got one more phone i can try
oh that's okay grandma you go we should
go and you go take your walk this is
annoying this phone i know we'll call
you later it's hard
to buy a new phone now because i don't
know how much longer i'm gonna be here
oh god okay we'll send you one are you
still there well maybe maybe well a
sponsor of the show will send you one uh
no we'll we'll talk to you later we'll
call you later okay honey okay we love
you love you i love you too
okay bye stay stay inside
okay
well
um she's constantly saying that uh that
she doesn't want to buy anything new she
doesn't want us to get or anything
the one that enrages me is the hearing
aid i think we talked about this when
she was on the show she's her hearing
aid is like 12 years old she does seem a
little bit more resigned to she seems a
little fixated on going out yeah and
coming up here yeah which is good i get
i get why she's feeling i mean
everyone's feeling claustrophobic but i
think especially older people who tend
to be a little more stubborn than
younger people
in certain ways
i think it's it's harder for them to to
not get to have their routine well old
people are very routine oriented our
father's
feeling frustrated and our mother too
yeah but she sounds a bit frustrated to
me and
i'm glad she has been staying inside you
know she also lives in a tiny little
condo and um
so yeah she's she sounds like she's
climbing the walls a little bit and i'm
sure many of you are uh
but i think
for the greater good um i i was curious
to know if she had any memories about
the spanish flu we could try her again
maybe when uh when she can when she has
i'm going to send her a phone she needs
a [ __ ] phone and a hearing aid if she
moves back up north
she might it might be easier to have her
honest
contributor
contributor
oh that'd be great um okay and right now
we're gonna check in as we have been for
the last few of these uh we're gonna
check in with our friend dr dave kessler
uh we actually someone wrote in with a
question specifically for dave
so hopefully he
dave's a little bit younger than our
grandmother so i think his hearing
might be a little hopefully better uh
we're going to try dave dr dave
hello yes
yes
that's how i like to start all my phone
calls too
either yes or no
yes um it in this case if it's no you
just hang up yeah uh hey buddy how are
you doing i'm good how are you guys
holding up
um pretty good really good yeah everyone
in the house is now seems to be 100
healthy maggie's taste which is the last
thing uh has come back for the most part
how
is everything dave for those of you who
have not been listening dave is on the
front lines in new york
at columbia med
how is it going there
how is it looking
um i could say i think the last time we
spoke uh we were expecting we were right
at the peak and plateauing and i think
we're
i think we're at the top of the mesa
right now um
you know
it is uh
it's still very high acuity patients are
very sick but um
we are able to keep up with it in terms
of our resources
and that was the fear right was that
there just wouldn't be enough
ventilators and would it be enough
equipment
yeah and i have to say like i mean i'm
certainly i'm uh in the loop on a lot of
things but we'll probably be learning
for weeks and months all the efforts you
know that we're going on simultaneously
that that brought us to this point where
um we had enough resources for the most
part i mean the caveat being of course
the rest of health care is more or less
shut down we're just one giant emergency
department in the city right now so yeah
that means you know routine surgeries
routine you know um uh you know business
as usual shut down of course christian's
very upset about not being able to get
his eye lift done
uh his brow lift um
dave at the risk of like we don't wanna
at the risk of getting political
although maybe it's hard not to at this
point um
what do you think about those i know a
lot of governors are resisting shutting
down
states and there's been talk of opening
the country back up from a scientific
standpoint what what would that really
do to any progress that's been made
opening up certain areas yeah
is there any um
[Music]
is there any scientific logic behind
maybe opening up certain areas
yeah well so i think um
the
the challenge here is now you know
science doesn't care about politics of
course um but i think that um
headlines aside
it is a really a good question about
what is best for health overall
um so if you if you give me a minute
here i'll try to explain
i think that
there are some
long-term you know implications and
short-term implications of not having um
uh you know as much access to care uh of
course we're meeting a lot of that with
telehealth right in terms of the economy
see one thing that we don't maybe maybe
like you know pre-code pre-coded we're
not talking about as commonly but it's
very clear to us in the er that um the
economy and healthcare are inextricably
linked you can't separate the two so
whether you're talking about the fact
that the majority of
americans in the current system get
their healthcare through their job um or
the fact that they're you know or the
other side of it right those who don't
have access to health care because they
don't have a job or they don't have the
kind of job that provides that so i
think that system itself i could tell
you uh you know a politically in the er
we've always seen how
the parts of it that don't work and
doesn't work for all americans and so
uh we really are at a a a crucial moment
as um a country to figure out what's it
going to look like yeah i mean one of
the reasons that britain nationalized
their health care was coming out of the
devastation of world war ii
um now i'm not saying that's the only
solution here but i'm saying what what
what we used to have uh didn't work yeah
and uh we need to find a way to make it
better so yeah but i've been hearing a
lot of people um and and we did we did
our share of this incorrectly i think
described this as the great equalizer um
an event like this and i think i i think
that's in inaccurate i think it's really
highlighting
all of the inequality uh that exists in
this country and i think the first and
foremost uh healthcare being being the
most um obvious one
it exposes the cracks in the system it's
like you took a a
a bowl a ceramic bowl that had a few
cracks you microwaved it and it blew up
you know and uh you're absolutely right
but i mean to answer i don't know if i
fully answered your question about the
state border thing well you know frankly
we don't know i think that you know and
as much as the intention behind it might
be that that there will be
real big implications for and you know
for
economy uh deteriorating there will be
so we have to figure out how to open up
eventually but i think that you know
we to do that safely from a scientific
standpoint
we're not there yet a hundred percent
because we don't have the testing we
need so we don't even know who has it
now that is coming online so maybe
that's part of this tri-state plan it is
it'll be in conjunction with that right
we yeah we were going to ask you about
that what they we had been hearing about
we talked about the antibody test um
something that we're chris and i are
eager to take uh i think thinking that
we had it um
when will that do you know when what's
going on with that when that's gonna be
available right and you know it's funny
because it sort of this highlights the
whole thing we're talking about right so
i know that there's already like uh you
know it's a free market economy people
are already buying them off the shelf
there's a lot of scams there too so you
got to be careful but there are tests
available at the same time our health
care workers are being offered the first
testing uh in you know in-house not
until i think tomorrow so wow
you know it's sort of like instead of
this being a coordinated effort on a
national level where we're doing it in a
scientifically sound way like yeah you
know first having our healthcare workers
be tested for example um you know
there's uh it's a little bit of a
free-for-all now yeah the new york state
response i think has been really really
good about this um and i think within
the week you know that will be more
routine in terms of the testing it's not
as simple as we talked i think on the
first episode it's not as simple as like
hey there's a test like not every test
is the same yeah there will be a lot of
competition out there there will be a
lot of difficulty in discerning what you
know what's good what's not and then
also we don't know what the immunity
means as you've seen in china and other
places that are starting to open up
there's second waves happening so
yeah i mean like
i i really hope that um
people just continue to educate
themselves and we start to shift the
conversation towards as you are towards
like well what does science say let's
listen to scientists yeah and when i say
and when i say that it's probably not
the same person as the the
sensationalist youtube video that like
that like knows something no one else
knows i've seen a lot of those my
friends and family asked about them
innocently i get it and they're they're
um
eroding the ability for us to trust on a
single scientific voice because people
start to question well you know are
these miracles out there
um that but dave that's surprising to
learn that of these tests yeah i would
have thought that there was just one
uniform you're talking about an antibody
test there's here's here's the test i'm
surprised to learn that there are
different products and different
companies creating these competing
competing for
something that seems so essential well
you you guys are uh
baseball fans right does everyone use
the same bat in the same baseball are
they all the same quality i mean you
know just because it's round doesn't
mean it's the same
quality and so tests are the same way
you know there's there's cheaper tests
there's better tests there's validation
of tests that are better than others and
then there's straight up scams out there
especially at a time like this
but that's surprising because i mean
baseball bats aren't it's so essential
to our survival like
you know i mean it can be if you're in a
dark alley
um but
in this case i would just think there
that the government would really get
behind
one you know
making this a priority and making this
centralized well that's the thing
they're not so i mean like like one
thing is then who do you turn to so like
you know our hospital um has been
working on this since day one and you
know part of the reason why it's not out
yet is because they want to make sure
that the test they use here is going to
be good now yeah um you know of course
funding comes into it so if the
government or the you know said like
let's just put all our money on this one
place then you know you can you can
optimize what's coming out i mean i'm
not opposed to
the
free market principle here and then i
think multiple places working on at the
same time also brings about you know
innovation a higher quality thing and
innovation but but it still hasn't
really been a concerted coordinated
effort on a national level you're right
about that um
hopefully we see that shift a little bit
yeah um i i have a question here usually
we read questions um at the end but uh
one specifically came in for you dave
and do you mind if i read it and ask you
this question oh no not at all uh okay
this is from stephanie hi guys hope
you're continuing to be on the mend
question for your doctor for your doctor
friend uh we have been told that it
takes about 14 days for symptoms of
covid19 to develop implying that after
14 days we likely don't have it this
seems counterintuitive because christian
and maggie have been symptomatic for
more than 21 days right i hear a lot of
stories of folks who have been sick for
longer if this is the case
why would we presume 14 days is the
quote safety zone
that's a good question
excellent question yeah she says someone
could have it and be asymptomatic for
who knows how long unless can you still
have the virus and not be infectious is
that what i'm missing or does the virus
die off while residual symptoms linger
what was her name again this is
stephanie
stephanie thank you so much for that
really astute question i think it
highlights the difference between policy
and science here so some of the
scientific papers she's absolutely
correct have shown a median of 20 days
of her symptoms um and when you do a
median that means that you're somewhere
in the middle so there are outliers on
either side right so that means some
people are like maggie's uh that well
how long has it been now 30 days mine
was 22 days but she yeah hers has been
30 with no taste yes so she's she's on
the outlying but but it highlights that
um
you know people you're absolutely right
people can be carried now how that how
that plays out in policy obviously
there's other factors there maybe
they're they're balancing sort of and
early on when they said 14 days maybe
they were balancing sort of the
information they knew at the time and
sort of economic implications and with
other influenza strains i mean is that
the typical that's more typical of other
what we know
you mean well infiling is a different
virus than coronavirus oh
you're writing that there's a range for
all viruses in general there's this
general range and again you pick
something i think in the past from a
public health standpoint you're picking
something that's practical not
necessarily because that's you know a
hundred percent of cases won't be
infectious for that long yeah you have
different policies just so you know like
when you come into the hospital and uh
you have the same virus that you might
tell someone something different for
when to return to daycare then you would
tell them if you're going to do you know
a liver transplant then you're going to
follow you know much stricter guidelines
that that uh
you know accompanied by which is
absolutely right and i think you know
what we saw from now that again
screening is a problem right so in our
hospitals um
ob gym program you know they they made a
decision early on despite you know the
fact that tests were scarce that one
priority they would have is testing
every single uh pregnant uh mother who
was coming in you know getting ready to
deliver and they just recently published
the study i think last week in the
naming journal of medicine um and i
might misquote the number exactly but
it's something around a 15 asymptomatic
terror grade so these were people who
didn't have any symptoms or think they
had covered but they were positive
that's an alarmingly high rate and it's
caused some of the epidemiologists i've
spoken to to start to to redo the
numbers based on what they originally
thought coming out of the data from
china in italy that
the uh the and we knew that there was a
lot of asymptomatic carriage but it
might be even higher than people thought
so for every test every number you see
reported of how many coveted positives
are in new york they're probably
doubling they're saying there might be
basic well originally they were saying
like one to ten and now they're thinking
you know even as high as one to a
hundred so there might be a hundred
times more cases going on than you've
been than are being reported oh my god
i mean anecdotally speaking like
the number of patients we test to the
ones that we see that you know probably
have it but we're not testing you know
including you and your brother right um
it it
that feels about right to me i mean that
you know um yeah a lot more than we're
testing yeah i just i talked to my
friend who's in sweden now and is conte
she's an actress and is continuing to
work they're they're doing productions
she's in the northern part of the
country and has been flying back to
stockholm and she said the um
the mindset there is that
every they're just
they're much more concerned with older
people and
people with pre-existing conditions
staying home and quarantining whereas
the rest of the for the most part um
the the rest of the country is not on as
strict a lot lockdown and and the idea
being that
everyone is going to eventually get it
like chickenpox yeah just like uh like
her community will develop so so there's
so yeah and i read that article i think
it's an interesting concept again like
you know no one knows the answers we'll
see what sort of happens there if that's
a smarter approach um or not it you know
the other thing is that
there's not like this isn't a
never-ending thing right so i do want to
push back on the herd immunity concept
because with herd immunity what happens
is a good portion of the herd dies off
first you know and then eventually it
sort of situates and so right you know
that might be inevitably what happens
despite all our efforts but from a
scientific uh innovation standpoint like
like and this is obviously i think gates
is probably pouring more money into this
than the government right now but in
terms of trying to rapidly develop a
vaccine um i mean that's going to be
what saves our parents lives right um
herd immunity is not going to help um
them per se yeah if it's so contagious i
mean the idea of hurt immunity is that
you know since some people are immune it
stops spreading um now with this virus
we are seeing people immune but still
carrying the disease so it's not clear
it's just not clear um you know when
we'll hit that point where the right
this burns out on its own and dave um
you talk about all the potentiality for
all so many asymptomatic cases is that
true of other viruses i mean is that
true let's say of influenza that that so
it's it's um
there's different rates for every virus
um and it's definitely true
and um
you know
when my kids were very young and um you
know someone would you know i could sort
of spot it like oh they have a little
runny nose and like oh i have allergies
and i'd be like oh no no no thanks like
we'll cancel the play date um you know
because you know
that is how things spread normally and
that's that person has a symptom in my
mind you can also have no symptoms at
all um but the difference here is that
you know normally you have a little
cough and a cold it's not killing lots
of people right right so so you know my
friends who have children who are
immunocompromised or undergoing
chemotherapy they're like yeah uh we've
been dealing with this forever you know
in terms of the you know being around
people who potentially spread yeah
because because a normal virus in that
case could be deadly to them so we're
all just experiencing
and you know
you know
like what um people who are you know
compromised may be feeling all the time
around those of us just carrying like
our little coughs and colds so but you
know coronavirus is really it's an
equalizer in that way and that it's
affecting not just the elderly not just
the immunocompromise we have otherwise
healthy you know 35 year old 22 year old
18 year old nine year old people who are
dying from this um and so that's i think
that's what really has everyone's
attention and what has everyone so
scared yeah well it is a scary time and
as always thanks dave thanks for filling
us in on this stuff and
for all your efforts on the front lines
it must be i can't imagine what it's
like for you and your colleagues right
now must be truly insane well it's
certainly um surreal i don't think i've
come out of that dream state yet but
i'll see you on the other side
thanks to stephanie for the great
question and and uh truly in fact uh
the the remainder of her letter i should
finish she says she says either way i
think messaging needs to change and
obviously yet another reason widespread
testing needs to happen before we get
back at it my boomer parents have been
isolating for weeks assume they are
clear and are now back to less than
ideal hygiene practices in the house
like coughing without covering their
mouths my mother has asthma and assumes
it's allergies she's 80
thoughts thanks in advance um and yeah
we have similar concerns about our own
parents you know just
and just relaxing um
once the curve does which it looks like
it is maybe starting to flatten um
it's flattening and that's again just
about resources to keep people alive but
we'd like to be we'd like to move
towards prevention
the better part of medicine that gets
ignored in this country you know the
amount of money going that goes towards
again you know uh
surgical things as opposed to sort of
primary care you know that needs to
change that you know if we're going to
come out of this but really you know i
think that um
i think it's a really good point
stephanie raised yeah yeah um i'm glad
that people are sort of uh
it's refreshing that they're
people out there paying attention to
science asking great questions
and uh not just listening to headlines
or whatever the sensationalist piece of
the day is yeah exactly that's going to
be where the pressure comes when the
public educates themselves right and and
instead of just you know listening to
what's being fed to us then i think we
put pressure on our local on our total
state federal governments to sort of get
the change we deserve well thank you
dave for answering those questions and
and for helping um to fill us in because
we're all scrambling to understand this
uh and so thank you so much thank you
we're all in this together thank you
guys uh okay
we'll talk to you soon dave thanks all
right bye-bye
um smart so smart and god
and if you guys have any questions like
stephanie had for
dr dave yeah feel free to write in and
ask them at uh life is short at
laundry.com that was a great question um
so this is uh a letter we're gonna read
no okay this is a letter uh
why did i have to repeat that you just
said it's a letter
that's a weird instinct
justin and christian hi from
post-apocalyptic toronto i hope you're
both uh staying safe and well and sane a
didn't write a i added that i'm sorry
i've been fluctuating between panic and
boredom the first few days i wandered
around my house like a chakovian
character when i got too bored i would
remind myself there's a killer did did
chekhov's characters wander i guess they
did they're always kind of suppressed
you so
easily said jacobian
shakarmian maybe
yeah i don't know you know i've never
seen that written um but i i love
chekhov and czechov chekovian um
i guess they do they they kind of
meander and they're kind of listless a
lot of checkouts yeah i guess they are
they're waiting another winter is upon
us you know
when will we get to moscow a lot of that
uh when i got too bored i would remind
myself there's a killer virus and that
spiced things up i've since settled into
somewhat of a routine writing baking
live stream yoga classes hey yoga with
tim yeah not an ad ddpy kind of an ad
taking walks and nodding at neighbors 10
feet away reaching out to friends and
watching justin trudeau get increasingly
frustrated as he realizes his polite
appeals aren't working
oh god i forgot they had justin
trudeau's leader that's cool what a
charmer i know my lord
toronto's great i love torontonians um
i learned that quarantine comes from the
italian for 40 days oh i didn't know
that so it's almost funny that this is
happening during lent it's
almost funny actually what's happening
is that i'm as i'm typing this my
dentist emailed to say he's available
for a virtual session for 150 presumably
so i can shove my phone camera into my
mouth and he can tell me i might have a
cavity that he can't do anything about
nice try dr bernstein and associates not
an ad
[Laughter]
um that's funny this person's funny i'm
grateful and i'm anxious
i'm grateful my sister is home i don't
get to see her most of the years oh no
sorry slipping into it as she lives in
dublin she's the person i laugh the most
with so it's great to have her around
that's cool i'm sure you can relate i
can i'm a writer and an actor so i'm
also grateful that i get to do at least
one of those things from home i have a
poorly timed grant from the canadian
government to develop one of my plays so
we now rehearse over zoom and are trying
to figure out how to live stream a play
reading isn't that amazing that the
canadian government uh gives grants to
things they really support the arts they
do
they do support the arts um and a lot of
their films come from uh public funding
yeah and they have to use a certain
percentage of canadian actors in the
recruit yeah i wonder what this pivot to
the digital will mean for art though i'm
quite wary of talking about art when
there are nurses and doctors and yes
grocery store workers risking their
lives and scientists trying to save us
all that is true i in fact i find i
really like balkan talking about
anything bulk
that's always been a tough one for you
yeah yep
uh what was the other i had a tough time
uh what did i say the other
adult adult or something yeah adult you
always make me repeat it
adult uh adjusting to uncertainties of
course
anxiety provoking i was a few weeks away
from moving back to new york on an
artist visa do you know these visas and
was meant to go to la for some pitch
meetings it they they give grants to go
to do pitch meetings i was canadian i
know
it seemed like everything was about to
come together in some way and it's all
up in the air now that's annoying but
we're all facing uncertainty we're in
the same boat which feels like a life
raft and i suppose things were always up
in the air we just like to pretend
they're not
i'm grateful that the earth is breathing
i'm grateful we have time to pause and
reflect and hopefully reconsider some
larger structures
uh it's true i hope we can learn to care
for one another better maybe this is our
saving grace
lastly i'm grateful i have your new
episode to look forward to now your
podcast always brightens my day that is
very nice i especially love the
interview post-mortem as i'm someone who
wishes i could discuss every
conversation i've ever had after it
happens i particularly love the jesse
eisenberg episode that might be how i
found this podcast i know jesse a little
bit from directing one of his plays here
in canada that's cool and hearing you
guys dissect that interview felt like
any conversation i've had with my sister
after any interaction i had with jesse
uh jesse is certainly
one it's a fun one to dissect
he is fascinating and so funny your mix
of enthusiasm and anxiety was both
validating and hilarious thank you both
for your work your openness your humor
uh i apologize for the length of this
email life is short but i have too much
time on my hands and as a canadian i
have to end on an apology
lots of love
veronica try lots of love again lots of
love veronica sorry
what a great letter uh veronica and it's
spelled the chichovian way with the k
maybe she's part russian maybe a russian
veronica
uh
yeah gratitude is important and it's
okay to acknowledge frustration i think
that all this [ __ ] was supposed to
happen i know and now i know on hold
yeah i know again this is i
hesitate to even indulge in this but
christian i feel lucky that we finished
this thing that we had been so this
creative endeavor that we've been so
looking forward to doing we finished
principal photography right before
uh the lockdown and all this happens so
we are now editing this movie um but it
might be a zoom yeah not an ad yeah
um and so we feel lucky to have that to
do and other things to keep us occupied
but um and as always we continue to feel
immense uh it's hard to put into words
the gratitude we have for people who are
uh working to try to end this um all the
health grocery store workers oh my god
you know the few times i've since gone
to the grocery store um i just feel i i
want to i can't thank them and you want
to hug them but you can't yeah exactly
that's the
i also i've been wondering lately
how because i think handshakes are going
to be a thing of the past once this is
over
and i keep wondering
what
the the hamstring what will be the new
handshake and i don't think it will be
the elbow bump although
i think that's
the most likely but i think it's going
to be something else it won't be bowing
because i don't think you know it's too
submissive i think whatever it is this
may be a positive that we're going to be
more deliberate about whatever it is
we're going to be we're going to be more
present for that moment of whatever that
because people started doing handshakes
and whatever the greeting is it became
just like a rote thing you know what i
think it's going to be it's going to be
some version of a nod it's either going
to be a downward nod or like a frat boy
upward nod yes
but there's gonna be some version of a
nod i bet a friend for not yeah
you know i have been nodding just that
having interactions with people on the
road when i've been driving me too
haven't you noticed maybe winking will
become a new handshake is that too
creepy yeah i think so i think so
uh and some people can't wink or blink
like a deliberate blink ah that's also
seems weird i'll see what you guys think
maybe a doff of the uh propeller beanie
oh full circle yeah um okay well uh if
you guys want to write in we are doffing
our propeller beanies to all of you
listening if you guys want to write in
with any anything really yeah how you're
making the most of your quarantine or
and or uh any
fun hypothetical questions
or we would love to read them or what
your suggestion for how we should greet
each other in the future yeah i'm
curious what people think yeah i've
always liked the japanese way but here
the the few people are just so far from
japan as a culture it's hard to imagine
us adopting that i know and they were in
island nation so it was easier for them
to be more
you know uh select uh what's the word uh
exclusive i mean
that can also that can go either way
that's too that's all right well thanks
for listening everybody
yeah thanks for thanks to grandma um
even though
even if she's listening she probably
won't hear this
we gotta get it that hearing thing i
normally she won't let me i know
i know i'm just gonna it's her achilles
heel
for 103 year old i like to be the one
thing that's really holding her back i
know silly it's really my fault i should
have just bought it she won't let me do
it but i'm just gonna buy it but it's
it's a couple thousand dollars for a
really nice state-of-the-art hearing aid
and and it would make and she keeps
every time i bring it up she's like oh
honey what do i need that for i'm gonna
we should get that for you i know really
stupid so we're gonna do that and thanks
to dr dave thanks again for his
wisdom and insight and um compassion
through all this totally really really
appreciate him and if you again if you
guys have questions for him please feel
free to write in and thanks for
listening thanks for staying in if
you're able to if you're not able to
thank you for
whatever the reason is you're not able
to and uh we'll see you see on tuesday
[Music]
life is short is hosted by you justin
long it's produced by you christian long
and megan monaco and the senior producer
is michelle miesh lans executive
producer audio audio engineer sorry
sergio enriquez and executive producers
are marshall louie andernan lopez for
wondering again as always we really
appreciate them doing these ad-free
see you soon
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
you